Welcome back to "Fashion As Design."
This week we're gonna talk about heroes.
Who is your fashion hero, Paola?
Well mine is... Cate Blanchett.
Good choice.
And Steph?
Mine is Gloria Steinem.
Nice choice also.
I would say mine is probably Claire McCardell,
a designer from the mid-century that Stephanie
told me about and I now love.
Well, what do we mean when we say fashion
hero, first of all?
It's a good question.
Well, I meant very simply what I want to look
like and also what I want to project.
So, hey, that's it.
And I think that could apply to a variety
of different types of people, be it a sports
hero, a pop cultural hero, an intellectual
hero even or a designer who's spearheading
what clothes look like.
Or all of the above.
Yeah.
So what are we going to get to look at in
this module?
So this week we have pulled together many
different types of heroes.
We're gonna look first and foremost at Bruce
Lee's original tracksuit which we had remade
by Bruce's daughter and by the Bruce Lee Foundation.
We started out with sports heroes and we talk
about sub-cultural heroes, about military
and political heroes, not to mention celebrities
and pop stars.
And then we ended up thinking, not even of
the present but of the future, landing on
Mars.
So when we talk about heroes, we mean the
wearer themselves imbues the garment or the
item with something and then it ultimately
allows other wearers to, perhaps aspire and
just admire that person.
And in so doing, try to wear the garment as
well and feel a little, a small sense of that
heroism.
Yeah, so is this really universal sense to
the idea of a hero or a fashion hero, the
idea that maybe we all know the Air Force
1 sneakers, for example, or we all at least
know that basketball and sneakers go hand
in hand.
But there's also this very personal sense
of aspiration, of emotion, of ways in which
we can be, by wearing something, [00:03:00]
maybe just a little bit closer to someone
that we all really admire.
Paola: And the idea is also that certain garments
can make you stand up taller even feel bigger
if you're small.
I'm always thinking of some of the smallest
heroes in history and I'm thinking of Prince
and I'm thinking of Bruce Lee who was actually...how
tall was he?
He was 5'7" or 5'8," I think.
He was quite a petite man and yet you wouldn't
be messing with him in a dark alley
at night.
No, and also seeing him...I mean, we know
that so many movie stars are smaller than
we think but he was really a giant in the
movies, right?
Yeah.
So I think that people will be amazed when
they will see the tracksuit but also they
will understand the power of the personalities
that fill the garments.
We're very happy that you spent another week
with us and we hope to see you next week again
for the course, "Fashion As Design."